thank you he thank you for all coming to
my talk uh I'm very glad to be here
today presid kuzu a graph databased
management system for python graph dat
science and my name is guon Jin I am a
currently a co-founder at C Inc which is
a startup company around kuu and prior
to that I was a post do at the
University of watu and that's also where
kzu started at a research project and
now it is open source and we actually
committed to building the community
around it with the goal of making it as
a system that you canu in for graph
science in Python world so um by looking
at the title I guess like many you have
some dos like already in your mind like
why graphs like why not tables why not
documents Etc and the reason is actually
U simple to me and I believe that graph
is one of the most nature the structures
or representations that you can find to
represent your application data and with
graphs we can abstract the beauty of it
is we can abstract data into entities
and relationships between them and view
them in object oriented way and I'm
going to show you like how this can
bring us some benefits so the first
benefit is that we can do Beyond
relational modeling and computations so
uh these these are things that normally
you are not able or you are not in to do
if you model data as tables for example
it will be more natural to think of your
data as to to snle path between entities
inside graphs instead of like modelism
or a bunch of tables also there are also
some like sem structured data like very
heterogenous knowledge graph that is
very hard or not easy to find a good
tabular
representation and secondly graph can
also make it more intuitive to impress
to express your queries find patterns
like example is finding Cycles across
entities which are like quite popular in
some applications such as fraud or risk
detection and so kuzu like other graph
database systems are built with those uh
benefits into consideration and kuzu
comes with uh the labeled property graph
model which is a popular adopted model
and we also adopt high level qu language
called CYO which is similar to se in
many ways and I want to show you one
example how the graph model combined
with the qu language can make certain
things easier and those are things you
don't really want to do them over tables
so here is an example of finding uh
recursive patterns so um the query is
that we want to find or direct or in
direct possible sources or money flow
into Al's account from Canada and uh
this uh if if you if you think of this
as tabl is going to be expressed in CLE
as recursive as uh recursive C is and
you will start your qu like uh with
recursive and I'm not going to show the
actual query here to uh simplify my
presentation but I encourage you to be a
TR to feel the difference and now if you
say what's presenting here as a CLE so
you just need to Simply append a star
after your Edge label uh which is
transform in in this query and uh so you
can uh feel the difference like how easy
it is to express a recursive pattern
with cyer and with a graph model and
another uh query I want to show is that
so let's make this a little bit even
harder like we we want to find the
shortest path of money that flows into
Al's account from Canada and so now uh I
don't really even want to try to write
this in with with CLE and but again if
you look at the query here that's WR in
sa you can find that still is quite easy
to express it you just need to append a
shortest keyword after the recursive
pattern so uh that is just one
example of how gra modeling combined
with the quer language can make things
easier especially when you want to uh
express your recursive pattern or like
there are so many cases like you want to
uh find unions or patents or you want to
quy your schema information together
with your actual data or like you you
get some uh data that's semi structured
and you want you can take the
flexibility of graphs to make it easier
to model so I'm not going to go into all
of the details on this here but uh we we
actually have a nicely to blog post on
our website uh so I put the link on the
on the right uh bottom part and you can
actually uh find all the details if
you're
interested and besides the EO modeling
and pattern finding and Cru at a system
uh specifically has have some other
benefits and one is that Cruiser is
actually embeded system so it makes it
easier to be integrated into a data
science pipelines and so uh compared to
the traditional server client more you
need to maintain a separate server you
need to deal with your config files you
U may also need to set up your access
controls and but that's just simply uh
for the case that maybe you just want to
uh do a quick overview or exploring over
your local data and you don't want to
bother with all of those efforts and uh
instead like kuzu is embedded and it's
easy to install and you can just simply
uh p and inside your python notbook or
your py script you can get started to
use it without all of those settings and
also K can make use of the their
copy uh benefits uh inside the same
process without transferring your data
between s and Cent
so besides that uh kuzu is a system
that's with a corner especially
optimized for graph for close and I want
to highlight one example why uh kuzu is
is is good for uh is fast it with in
terms of finding patterns so one uh
common thing that's in graph for close
is that you typically would get growing
uh like you you would get some pattern
that your qu result is going to be exp
exponentially growing and so if you take
a look at the graph on the left bottom
corner so we have a buol A's a bunol B's
and a bunol c's and HP is actually quite
densely connected which uh around 1008
and around 100 C's and we have a query
that's very simple we want to find all
the connected a and C's to one uh know
which which is Leist uh in this case so
traditionally uh in most in almost every
de system the the size of the
intermediate result which is a which is
a common way to uh in theem me the
complexity of the query will actually
grow exponentially to square 100 while
in Cru we can uh come up with a way that
compress the query result in a very
exact way to reduce the size to be uh
linear growing instead of exponentially
growing and this can greatly boost our
quer performance so this is one high
level overview of kuz's internal
architecture to make pattern findings
faster also kuzu comes with other uh
State art solution that way we
understand like re execution column
storage and uh predefined Point based
joints and from no joint AC for certain
patterns and I'm not going to discuss
this details here again so for simplity
so but you can find the details and
pointers for our res works on our block
post or from our paper on on on the
conferences yeah and to summarize a
little bit here so what kuzu is kuzu is
a a graph database system in the first
place but more specifically kuu is in
process analytic graph system that's
optimized for graph designs in the P
world and we if if you if you're aware
of CB you can interpret uh kuu as c d
graphs and other embeded system where
can take the one user copy or possible
and another different another
dimensional different C from other
system library that we actually aims to
be a high scalable one that's on as a
single node system so it is disk based
and it is also optimized for mtic parm
and some of the techniques are based on
our resarch works and our understandings
of the of the uh State techniques so
lastly because is free and it is open
source with uh MIT license so you can
give a try and do anything you want on
top of it and it's also easy to install
as present libraries just do people
install
kuzu and in a very high level view uh
kuz actually aims for two things in for
graph dat science in Python world so the
first thing is that we a we aim to make
it easy for you to inest your data and
model it has graphs and also exchange
your graph between different f m between
different libraries and even between
different systems so for now uh what we
support is that you can inest data from
C3 fil par fil and also from Panda dat
frames and also C can export the to
network X to pandas and uh to arrow and
also we have some T integration with IG
for your graph learning pipelines and
you can uh also use kuzu as the as P
remote backend which is a quite Advanced
feature allow you to train your graph
when your graph doing fit in memory and
uh another thing to note is that this
libraries and things and system uh
supported by kuu is is not just graph
ones but also graph ones and also with
typle ones so uh Cru can actually bre
gaps between these two
models and uh so there are more
integration that's coming and showing in
in the as dra the figure is kind of like
a vision we aim to support and we also
plan to support defining graph schema
inside Cal or relational systems uh like
post gr so you can let us know if you
got interest spe in this features
and technically what C aims is to make
the integration cleaning and transform
and
excting of the graph e there uh using
the high level qu language and also
quite powerful corner and the example
might be like this so you got uh in you
have inest your data from varus sources
and then you uh extract your sub graph
out you might do some graph realization
and well some graph algorithms uh
through Network X or you would run some
gr learning pipelines to p and then fit
your result back to K through pandas and
you can also export the data to uh your
relational pipelines through
Arrow so I want to uh give give you a
quick uh two actually two demos so one
is that how we can uh
use one sec how we can use kuu uh so
basic so first uh basic operations
include that how you can define a graph
schema uh which which is consisting
consist of node and relational tables
and how you can load those data into the
database and how we give a demo on how
we can integrate that with network X for
verition and also to make use all
Network x uh to do some graph uh
algorithm and also how we can just data
from panel and also export qu fin
so uh we would be using a very popular
uh dat set but it's also a very simple
one so the schema is called mov lens and
the schema is consisting four tables two
note table user and moving and two
relation table taex and race and we
would use race mostly in thiso and we
use a small version of the data set uh
just to make same go quicker uh to for
the for the demo simp pleas do demo and
so let's get started by installing KU
and networks here and we're also going
to import some libraries for demo and um
cleaning up uh the database directory
and download some CS3
files
um yeah just wait a bit and let me see
if we got some
questions so uh is it's Cru native graph
DB yes so kuzu is a native graph DB and
we have our own data storage uh we
currently we don't support encryption
and so if you mean
the if you mean like you are accessing
kuu in rest for uh so we actually don't
support that
um yeah but we we are native and we
support we have our own data storage and
our query
processor can you R any not to Vector on
oh
um can show this so you can't directly
run not to Vector inside kuu but but you
can definitely uh export export the not
FES outside kuu to whatever Library you
want to use and one not Vector on that
and we support the vector dat type which
is called Fix list in kzu and you can
easily adjust them back inside
kzu and let's get uh back to our demo
for a while and I get back I get back to
Q yeah so we have done the install and
import let's uh just simply download
some CSV
files and the first step is uh in the
demo is we need we need to First create
kuzu database objects and as kuu is
actually on this system so we need to
pass a local directory path uh that will
hold all of the database files and and
also create a connection so uh simply
bance here and the first step I want to
explain that uh when you want to load
data into kuu that we first need to
define a set of node and directory
relations and through some create no
table create table statements and these
are quite similar to stles create table
for example to create node we would
Define some properties and also specify
a primary key which which will Sol at
the unique identifier for each node and
also for creating real that we are
defining from which node table to uh
another mode table and you can also
define the properties and so let's do
this uh we so after defining the schema
now we can start loading the data from
our say refile just uh simply we use the
simplest way is to use copy and this is
good for the back
loading and first we before we go to
more um like first first let's veraly
the graph a little bit so uh I want to
just uh show the ability that you can uh
you can run query that's returning all
of the uh nodes and real but uh we don't
want to export all of them that's going
to slow the realization in network Cas
but so uh I just limit 300 RS here and
we can we can say how they look inside
the network X simply realization now get
some uh graph that you'll find that okay
some use uh that's rated has rated lot
of movies uh the red is USA and the blue
one is
movie
and and next I want to demo that how you
can actually combine KU with networks to
uh do more complicated things uh you can
use Network X for graph algorithm and
you can use kuu for uh pattern findings
and the case is that we want to
recommend movs to users by just finding
some other users who share similar taste
and also those movs are highly rated by
those uh by those users who who who
share the same tast and we want to uh to
do that we first create a new
relationship table similar taste between
uh between users and so that done way
can extract a pair of users who have
really the so basically the definition
is to extract a pair of users who have
read the same movie and that kind of
recent let's say after 2015 and with
quite high scores uh let's say larger or
equal than 4.8 and create a relationship
between them so you can simply do that
we first create real table and then we
Define some pattern of for is from uh
you one to a movie that's was rated by U
and we have another pattern that's from
U2 to the same movie so we find the
users who has rated the same movie and
we put some filters on ratings on the
year of the movie and also of course we
don't want to find the uh user that that
that's uh becoming self between them so
we then we use we can use create
statement to create new relationships
between uh each pair of users
and so that can be simply easily done
and after the extraction uh let's let's
say how the new relationship looks like
uh okay I don't know why but my laptop
is getting a little
bit
okay yeah so
so from the graph we can say that
actually there are some uh wable classes
of the users in in in the graph that
they tend to share same T more than
compared to others and now an idea comes
to us that we can just do one H step
further that we we decide to perform
some Community detection in network X
and then use that
uh to further to to polish the
recommendation and we uh just choose to
use a classic one that's called
government new community detection
algorithm for a list of community
detection algorithm provided by Network
X so
um yeah so this is this is similar to
the previous uh code block that we
export the the relationship to network X
and call the Govern new to do the
community detection and I'm going to
omit the code that's performing the
realization of the results so they are
just sightly modified from the example
provided by Network's official website
and let's give wrong and we can say from
the graph here uh we got five
communities and some are large and some
are quite small like with only one user
and we can also uh convert the result of
community detection from Network into a
data frame with two columns one is the
user ID and the other one is the
community ID that the user is in and
print the data frame we can see that uh
we got lot of users in the community one
and some quite a few in two and uh yeah
much less in three four five
and now we can do what we can do is that
we can export this result back to kuzu
by out our user table to add a new
property called community and um through
the rate pandas score we can uh
integrate them and update the community
value with the one that's found by the
community detection
algorithm spe around and finally let's
say we want to make a recommendation for
some user well say the user is ID 15 and
what what we can do is that we can find
the r Mo way that after 2015 that the
users in the same Community with user 15
and move is that those users have highly
rting uh say like the rating is larger
equal 4.8 and but not yet rated by us 15
right so we don't want to recommend
movies that the user has has watched
already and also we can order the return
return titles by their highest rating
and Export the query result to pandas
and print the result out uh so what we
do here is that we first find the mov
cre by user 15 and uh collect them into
a list movies you want and then we find
we express another pattern that's to
find uh users that within the same
community with us
15 but it's not us 15 of course and uh
with the the last pattern is that we
find that uh users who have done highly
rated uh find the highly rated movies by
uh U2 us two and the movies are recent
and also uh those movies are not rated
how rated by user one and we return the
result um in and all by them by the
highest
rating so we got a bunch of movies that
we can recommend now and they are sorted
in the by the highest rated
order okay so that's the first demo I
think I still got some time uh let me
back to the Q
a so how does crew do compared to with
commercial graph basis such as new
and um so first of all we we are
actually uh open source like is like
also has open source project but we are
uh committed to building the open source
community and kuzu is actually embedded
so uh it's not so Cent mode that's U
that that's something we we we intend
to where we choose to do is because we
want to be highly integrated with the
python uh ecosystem data science
ecosystem and uh for the integration
with GNN right now we have integration
with p g so but you cannot you cannot do
gen and TR andite C but you can very
easily uh export your qu result outside
to p g and perform the trainings and we
actually have
two uh
examples say to collapse let show how
you can do node property detection
prediction or like link prediction uh
combined kuzu with P hope this answers
your
question
um yeah or any Yad map on AI models uh
so we are definitely looking at the
Vector combination Vector SE Vector
index with graph but uh that's not we
don't have uh things uh yeah we don't we
don't have features that will be that's
that's public yet
so uh machine learning or AI models um
we don't support models directly inside
kuu but so one thing is that uh we be
able to add support extensions that you
can Define some sub modules and that can
so like Rong uh or that can run inside
kuzu but uh we don't aim to right now we
don't aim to do everything that KU so we
want to be the one that can easily
integrate everyone that
can like you can find the best Library
uh for for for each task for you and but
you can exchange data very easily
between between them
kuu uh yeah sure I will share the
notebook and I will update them in the
in our website so you can have
that
um yeah so let me quickly show another
demo that uh we also have a web Explorer
that's a web that's a browser based user
interface so you can realize your query
result you can you can also Define uh
your schema in the world way and this is
also open source project under the C
organization in GitHub and
um so it
can be used in several ways one is that
you can start a start a Explorer like is
a doc image so pointing to an existing
database locally you have or you can
just start with empty1 and play around
with it so for Simplicity I just start
with mp1 and I uh so this is the
interface so we have a shell that you
can issue that you can issue queries and
then we have a some uh data sets uh that
you can uh prebuild this set you can
load so I loaded the C demo here and
then you can say the uh
schema uh so I just want to quickly
Demo First how uh the query realization
works so I would just write a very
simple query that you can uh extract the
whole graph and the weiz them and this
is
the uh reliz the result and in the right
side there is a set panel that you can
actually say uh the properties of each
node and and
well and also the query result comes
with t view and also uh Json
View and if you provide uh as your uh
chart GPD key uh inside the settings so
I don't want to show that um so you can
also uh issue queries with natural
language for example I want to say how
many users do I have in the
database and it would generate the
corresponding s queries for you and you
can you can actually View and make edits
on generated s query and also the qu
result so let's try
something else so since we are in what
to let's say I use that located
in yeah so you would get a more
complicated query that's WR by gbt um so
as for schema uh you can Define you can
make a change edit your schemas uh in
the schema panel and say we can uh add
new
node
director name be
scen hi
we're actually over time right now if
you want oh sorry for that yeah so
that's that's it and we also uh have it
on our demo website and thank you that's
all